have you ever started learning a
language with a huge boost of motivation
only to see that motivation disappear
within months weeks or even days i have
and even after dedicating 30 years of my
life to language learning i'm well aware
how dangerous a lack of motivation can
be for any language goal great or small
i've seen it in my students as well in a
decade of working as a language coach
i've heard hundreds of stories about how
motivation can dry up just when you need
it most if that's happened to you then i
have good news that doesn't have to be
how your language learning story ends
with the right strategies you can
develop your capacity to create
motivation on demand so you have enough
for every leg of your journey towards
fluency and today i'm going to teach you
those strategies hello i'm luka
lampariello i'm a language coach who
speaks 14 languages and on this channel
i help people learn foreign languages
more efficiently faster and in a fun way
let's dive right in whether or not
you're trying to learn a language before
i'm sure it's obvious to you that
language learning requires effort what's
perhaps not so obvious to people is how
long they have to wait until they see
some kind of reward people have taken
language classes in school might have
never seen a reward for their learning
efforts
they just remember having to fill in
perp tables do endless grammar drills
and copy vocabulary list after
vocabulary list there's little to no fun
in any of this so
motivation is scarce even independent
learners who usually avoid some of the
most boring staples of traditional
language learning often find themselves
caught in an initial stage where they
spend more time with their head in
language books than they do actually
using the language in a productive way
since these learners have some choice
and what and how they learn they usually
find the period more motivating this
specific period more motivating than
traditional learners do but many people
still get stuck at this stage i've
learned all of my languages
independently and yet this sit and study
period is not at all what motivates me
to keep learning languages in reality
the most motivating part of the language
learning process is typically what comes
after this period when i know enough
language to actually use it in real life
when my sit and study period comes to an
end is exactly when i start living the
language this is when i do all sorts of
fun and exciting things for example
having conversations with native
speakers reading target language books
watching target language tv and movies
traveling in the country or countries
where the language the target language
is spoken and so much more to me these
are the most life-changing parts of
learning any language and exactly what i
look forward to when i start out as a
beginner but if you've never reached
this stage or you haven't reached it
just yet in the language you're
currently learning how can you develop
and maintain enough motivation to get
you there how can you stay motivated
enough during the sit and study stage to
eventually see the fruits of all of your
efforts and of your language learning
labor so to speak i personally use four
powerful motivation strategies which i
will show you in detail just right now
first imagine your way to fluency if you
know your why you will discover your how
in a nutshell this quote explains
exactly what has allowed me to learn 13
foreign languages and for each language
i've learned i worked hard to discover
exactly why i needed to learn that
language and make it a key part of my
life if you want to learn your target
language well you'll need to find your
why as well but knowing your why is not
an automatic recipe for fluency
oftentimes a certain why is completely
inaccessible at the beginner level of
learning a language so you need to take
an extra step to borrow motivation from
that why until you can actually make it
a reality for example a common why of
mine for language learning is to build
deep connections with native speakers in
their own language when i'm a beginner
cannot string two words together in a
language making such deep connection is
just impossible to bridge the gap
between a beginner me and the version of
myself who can actually achieve that
purpose i use the power of my own
imagination specifically i close my eyes
and visualize myself months or years in
the future after i've gotten past the
sit and study phase
and i'm comfortable enough to live my
life in the target language in my mind's
eye i watch myself as i make friends
using the language and smile laugh and
have fun alongside native speakers i may
even picture myself traveling within the
country or visiting famous landmarks
with new friends this is exactly what i
do with every new language i learn to
this day i can even remember the images
they conjured up years ago when learning
german before i had even ever set foot
in germany images that i thought of
every day before sitting down and you
know hitting the books the funny thing
is that now even after i've reached
fluency in german and spent lots of time
in germany i still find those images to
be immensely motivating here's how you
can use your why to build a powerful
visualization that can fuel your
motivation for ears first of all you
need to find your why think about the
kinds of things you want to do when you
are a skilled user of your target
language for me it's usually traveling
making friends but for you it may be
different find a quiet distraction free
place and sit down with a pen and paper
take a moment to close your eyes and try
to mentally picture yourself doing all
of those things you listed as part of
your why and the last step try to flash
out the mental picture as much as
possible and ask yourself questions like
who am i with
what am i doing
where am i doing this and what and once
your visualization is sufficiently vivid
write down a description of it in words
it can be as long as you'd like but mine
is generally around 200 350 words keep
your written visualization with you or
at least near your study place and
before you sit down to learn each day
read what you've written and try to
picture it again in your mind if you
complete the steps you'll have a
powerful source of motivation that will
pull you into your desired future you
may even find that one day your
visualization will come true as many of
mine have two focus on systems rather
than goals most beginner language
learners are consistently stuck asking
themselves one question over and over
and over again when am i going to
finally become fluent in my target
language i understand why this is
heck i used to be in exactly the same
way just like on any language journey or
any journey in general it's easy to find
yourself wondering are we there just yet
or
my decades of language learning however
i've learned that these kinds of
goal-based questions are not useful it's
impossible to say exactly when any
language learner will definitely reach
fluency so obsessing about it will not
do anyone any good instead of goal based
questions i found that it's much better
to ask
system-based questions while goal-based
questions have answers that are often
either difficult or impossible to know
system-based questions have useful
answers that you can actually come up
with on the spot for
immediate impact good system-based
questions for language learners include
for example questions such as when can i
next sit down to learn my target
language how long can i dedicate to my
language learning today how can i make
it easier to start my next learning
session what can i do the next time i
don't feel motivated to sit down and
learn all or most of these system-based
questions have answers that are
repeatable for example if you know how
long you can dedicate to your language
learning today you'll likely be able to
determine how long you can dedicate to
your language learning tomorrow as well
at the very least the question helps you
brainstorm about how much time you can
dedicate to your language earning in the
very near future which creates value in
the here and now unlike goal goal-based
questions over time asking yourself
system-based questions will help you
create reliable systems and schedules
that will lead you towards any goal for
example if you develop a system through
which you spend 30 to 45 minutes every
day learning your target language then
you'll eventually become fluent even if
you never actually worry about when you
will get there here are some suggestions
that can help you build powerful systems
for your own learning set aside a weekly
block of time that is completely
separate from your learning time
this will help your plan session
which you will use to reflect on your
language learning efforts from the
previous week and ask yourself
system-based questions that will improve
the efficiency of your language learning
for the coming week try to identify the
strengths and weaknesses of your current
learning plan and use that information
to modify your plan for the future
devote a realistic chunk of time to
language learning every single day other
than planning the next system you will
need involves actually sitting down
and learn decide on the length of time
you can spend each day in learning and
mark it on your schedule i recommend
starting with 15 30 or even 45 minute
blocks to avoid becoming overwhelmed you
can always increase that later if it's
necessary develop a contingency plan for
your daily learning sometimes life can
get in the way in your language learning
schedule and have a plan uh in place so
that if you need to skip a learning
session you can make up that learning
time somewhere else in your day and make
sure that even if you do need to skip
one day of learning you never skip two
days and risk breaking your learning
habit in many ways systems are more
powerful than goals because they keep
you focused on the ways in which you are
taking action towards your goal and make
the overall process of learning easier
smoother and more habitual three aim for
the goldilocks zone when you were a kid
did your parents ever tell you to finish
your vegetables whether we intend to or
not we often feel like we have to finish
the things we start simply because we've
been taught it's the right thing to do
we finish books we do not like we eat
meals we do not enjoy and we sit through
tv series that got stale halfway through
just so we can say we
finished what we started but while that
is often a useful rule in daily life
it's not always useful when learning i
can still remember when a couple of
years ago i was coaching a student who
was learning german like many of my
other students i had taught him how to
apply my bi-directional translation
method to the astronaut course books
which typically contain anywhere from 80
to 100 dialogues originally it seemed
that his heart was set on applying my
method to every lesson of the book from
start to finish
gradually though i noticed that his
passion for the asthma lessons began to
wane and one day during a lesson he had
with me he said um luca listen i i love
your method and i love austin mill but
i've had enough of these dialects and
what should i do and i think he expected
me to be upset a little bit or say
something along the lines of just just
stick with it you know just power
through and until the end and everything
will be fine but actually i did not
instead i i told him
he could draw a passimo right away and
move to another activity and another
resource and it did not have to finish
all the lessons of asamil so
why did i let him stop even though he
technically had a lot you know more
material that he could cover with asimo
because he no longer found it enjoyable
or challenging and enjoyment and and and
challenge should be the two things at
the heart of any learning activity you
do and any other learner should do at
any level to maintain motivation while
learning a language you should
constantly assess and reassess your
learning activities to ensure that you
find them fun rather than boring and
find them neither too easy
nor too difficult in other words you
want to make sure that every activity
that you do is in the language learning
equivalent of the goldilocks zone now if
you remember the tale of goldilocks and
the three bears you'll understand the
concept just as goldilocks did not like
her soup to be too cold nor too hot you
do not want your learning activities to
fall into the extremes of too easy too
hard or too boring though i'm not sure
there's anything wrong with a learning
activity that's too fun identifying
learning activities that fall within the
special zone also has a very powerful
impact on your motivation as well author
james clear noticed that when he wrote
if you find yourself feeling unmotivated
to work on a task it is often because it
has drifted into an area of boredom or
been shoved into an area of great
difficulty you need to find a way to
pull your tasks back to the border of
your abilities where you feel challenged
but capable so that's why i recommend
for you here to
maintain long-term motivation you need a
plan to consistently keep yourself in
the goldilocks zone and the best way to
do this in my opinion is to regularly
ask yourself if you find your learning
activities fun and challenging revise
your language learning plan every three
to six months establish meaningful
relationships this is something i teased
a bit when talking about my personal why
but it's powerful enough that i feel it
deserves its own point to stay motivated
over the long term seek out meaningful
relationships with native speakers
whether you are introverted or
extroverted i think you will agree that
human beings are social creatures we
derive much
if not all of our happiness and
well-being from engaging with people we
care about and who care about us as
beginner language learners it's easy to
feel like there's a wall between you
and any native speaker you might connect
with you either feel too
inexperienced or too uncomfortable to
engage with them and as a result of this
you retreat into things that feel more
comfortable but that are more difficult
to connect with at a human level at
least books videos apps and so on and
even if you're stuck in the sit and
study stage i recommend finding ways to
build personal connection into your
language learning life you can try
things for example such as visualizing
yourself connecting with native speakers
which i spoke about earlier or joining
online or in-person meetup groups about
your target language or culture you can
hire a tutor you can find a language
partner even as a beginner you can find
value and connection in all of these
things in my experience if you're lucky
enough to form a strong bond with a
native speaker that bond will act as a
powerful motivator that will spur you to
get better and better in the language
and on top of that you'll have a
wonderful source of feedback and
encouragement i've developed these
connections in nearly every single
language i've learned
through language learning i've met many
incredible people with whom i've shared
countless adventurous and life-changing
experiences and all of those things
together have created a wonderful source
of motivation that has kept me learning
for decades on end if you establish a
meaningful relationships with native
speakers and with people in general i'm
certain that you too can develop such an
endless source of motivation and there
you go you now have a powerful set of
four strategies you can put to use to
create and maintain motivation for ears
and ears to come this makes the end of
my three-part video series of how to
start learning any language first we
covered simple steps for getting started
then we covered the power of translation
and lastly we touched upon
motivation if you've watched all three
videos in the series so far thank you so
much and if not be sure to check in the
the description box for links
to the other two videos you will not
want to miss those ones and last but not
least if you've enjoyed what i have
shared in the series and would like to
dive deeper into my personal methods for
learning a language from scratch then i
invite you to check the description box
again for a link to my brand new online
course which will provide you with more
in-depth strategies for mastering any
language and as always thanks for
watching and happy language learning
[Music]
[Music]
you